do you think it's possible that
life from other solar systems was
injected
and that that was what was uh the origin
of life on earth
yeah the panspermia idea um
that's seen as a low probability event
by people who studied the original life
but that's because
uh then they would be out of a job well
i don't think they'd be out of the job
because you just then say you have to
figure out how life started
and there but then you have to go there
we can study
life on earth much easier we could study
in the lab
much easier because we could replicate
conditions that are
from an early earth much easier
from a chemistry perspective from a
biology perspective
you can intuit a bunch of stuff you can
look at different parts of
earth and just to an extent i mean the
early earth was completely unlike the
current earth right there was no oxygen
so uh one of my colleagues at caltech
uh joe kirschneck is
um certain right something like
100 certainty that life started on mars
and
came to earth uh in on martian media
rights
this is not a problem that
i like to kind of think about too much
like the origin of life it's a
fascinating problem but
you know it's not physics and i just
like i just don't
don't love it it's the same reason you
don't love i thought you're a musician
so music is not physics either so why
why are you so
100 physics
[Laughter]
okay no no look uh in all seriousness
though i
uh there are a few things that i really
really enjoy
i genuinely enjoy physics i genuinely
enjoy music
i genuinely you know enjoy martial arts
and i
genuinely enjoy uh my family i should
have said that all
in a reverse order or something but i
like to focus
on these things and and not worry too
much about
about everything else you know what i
mean yes just because there is a like
you
said earlier there's a time constraint
you can't
do it all there's many mysteries all
around us
so um and they're all beautiful in in
different ways
to me that thing i love is artificial
intelligence that
perhaps i love it because eventually i'm
trying to suck up to our future
overlords
you